hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 54
hört zu und spricht nach
feiern
feiern ich feiere ich feiere
du feierst du
erst er sie es feiert er sie es feiert
wir feiern wie
ihr feiert ihr feiert sie feiern
sie feiern wie
hast du deinen geburtstag gefeiert
wie hast du deinen geburtstag gefeiert
ich habe meinen geburtstag bei mir zu
hause gefeiert
sich verkleiden
ich verkleide
für mich
ich war klar
nicht du verkleidet dich
leides dich er sie es verkleidet sich er
sie es verkleidet sich
wir verkleiden uns
ihr verkleidet euch ihr verkleidet euch
sie vergleicht
sie verkleidet
hast du dich verkleidet hast du dich für
klar
ja ich habe eine maske getragen
amys august ist schweizer
nationalfeiertag
am ersten august ist schweizer
ich habe am zweiten juni geburtstag
ich habe
juni geburtstag
die para
ist am dritten juli
die paar
tee ist am dritten juli
am 6 dezember ist sankt nikolaus tag
am sechsten dezember ist nikolaustag
am 11 november beginnt in basel die
fasnacht
fasnacht am 24 und 25
dezember sind weihnachten
am 24 25
an weihnachten steht in vielen
wohnzimmern ein geschmückter christbaum
am 31 dezember ist silvester
um mitternacht stößt man mit champagner
oder prosecco an
im sommer gibt es in der ganzen schweiz
open airs
im frühling findet in zürich das
sechseläuten statt
im herbst findet das oktoberfest in
münchen statt
im winter gibt es viele feiertage
am ersten august 1291 haben die kantone
uri schwyz und unterwalden die schweiz
gegründet
am ersten august 1291 haben die kantone
uri schwyz und unterwalden die schweiz
gegründet
im jahr 1969 sind die menschen zum
ersten mal auf dem mond gelandet
ich bin am 4
august 1981 geboren
deutschland
sich 1990 wieder vereint
1990 wieder vereint
schöne feiertage
schöne feiertage frohe weihnachten
frohe weihnachten
herzliche grad
nation zum geburtstag herzliche
gratulation zum geburtstag
ein frohes neues jahr
alles gute zur hochzeit alles gute zur
hochzeit gesundheit gesundheit
prost zum wohl
post zum wohl
gute besserung
[Musik]